the metaphor is sort of like it
represents the dematerializations of the
world as we know it it's sort of the
virtualization of identity expressions
and interactions
and then in the metaverse there would
also be an economy where people can then
buy sell create and trade with virtual
goods
[Music]
to think about what fashion in the
metaverse looks like i think it's
helpful to think about what fashion
needs in the first place right and i
think people have different definitions
but the way that we have been thinking
about it is as fashion is the way that
people express themselves in the past
when you think about physical fashions
the way you express yourself has been
kind of hinged on your physical aspects
like how you look your race your genders
all of that stuff what fashion looks
like in the metaverse or at least the
promise of it is that you will be able
to express yourself beyond your physical
aspect i can dress
in like a female body i can dress in
with flame around me because physic
doesn't exist in the middle
it would be more free more expressive
they're starting to compare nft as a new
cologne for fashion brands
because in the past when you could not
afford a piece of very expensive louis
vuitton or like calvin klein clothes you
buy a cologne because it's cheaper yet
it gets you the buying into that circle
it gets you this impression that you are
now a part of something larger and that
is your expression these individuals and
gamers can purchase a
let's say montclair or gucci item for
like only like 10 bucks for example
way lesser than in the physical world
but in doing so you're kind of like oh
now i'm part of it i own
a gucci item i own a product item with
the people that i am hanging out in this
game i find it interesting because it
provides alternative models for people
who are trying to find a way to express
themselves
in the middle verse my concern with
fashion in the middle of it has to do
with my concern with fashion
in the real world right just over the
past years we've heard lots of reports
about children being cyberbully because
they could not afford a piece of
expensive items in like a video game
there was a beta tester for this
metaphors platform that you could go in
and then the beta tester is probably
being groped um in the metaverse so all
of these things will continue to exist
it is inherently a human issue right
like yes technology can amplify these
problems but at the end of the day it is
the humans are causing the problem so in
a world where we're becoming ever more
virtual i think it's important for every
metaverse builders or agency to
recognize that there's a person behind
avatar
there's a lot of money and investment
that's going into the metaverse for both
good and bad reason and when there's a
lot of money and there's a lot of power
at times in the past you notice that
things gonna get chuffed on you and the
best way to fight against that is to be
a bit more educated by understanding
what is the metaverse what are the goods
what are the bets and thinking how can
you fight for the goods and mitigate the
bats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you